good morning Hank it's Tuesday I'm still
on vacation so here's some more horizon
today I'll be reviewing man's capacity
for wonder the phrase comes from a line
in F scott Fitzgerald's novel The Great
Gatsby in which the narrator imagines
Europeans first arriving in the Americas
for a transitory enchanted moment
Fitzgerald writes man must have held his
breath in the presence of this continent
compelled into an aesthetic
contemplation he neither understood nor
desired face to face for the last time
in history with something commensurate
to his capacity for wonder the line
comes right at the end of the novel and
it's always seemed to me slightly out of
place as if Fitzgerald realized he
couldn't write the Great American Novel
without one moment of zooming out to
examine the quote unquote beginning of
the quote unquote history of his
continent and of course now it feels
wrong on a few levels there's the
gendered language the false notion that
America was somehow empty or pristine
before Europeans arrived and the fact
that within a few decades of the Great
Gatsby humans would step foot on the
moon and glimpse what the universe
looked like just after the Big Bang by
gazing upon 16 billion year old light
still Fitzgerald's business about man's
capacity for wonder is an awfully good
wine so good in fact that it's easy to
mistake it for true like beautiful
arresting observations always seem
accurate even when they're not take for
instance the masterful first line of
Anna Karenina all happy families are
alike each unhappy family is unhappy in
its own way
we know this observation is too
reductive to be strictly speaking true
but still we love it not least because
most of us find comfort in the idea that
if we aren't going to be happy we might
at least be unique in fact I suspect
most of us deep down would rather be
interesting than happy I know I would
now the best observations in literature
are at once beautiful and broadly true
ships at a distance have every man's
wish on boards or Neale Hurston wrote or
this line from Kurt Vonnegut we are what
we pretend to be so we must be very
careful what we pretend to be but often
a great line doesn't prove to be a great
truth like I remember when my son was
about 2 we were walking in the woods one
November morning we were along a ridge
looking down at the forest below where a
cold haze seemed to hug the forest floor
and you could see out across the forest
below us for miles and it was just so
extravagantly beautiful and I kept
trying to get my oblivious 2 year-old to
appreciate this
landscape at one point I picked him up
and pointed out toward the horizon and
said look at that Henry just look at it
and he said leaf what I said and he said
leaf again and then reached out and
grabbed a single brown oak leaf from the
little tree next to us I wanted to
explain to him that you could see a
brown oak leaf literally anywhere in the
eastern United States in November that
nothing in the forest was less
interesting but after watching him look
at it
I began to look as well and I soon
realized it wasn't just a brown leaf its
veins spider doubt red and orange and
yellow and a pattern too complex for my
brain to synthesize and the more I
looked at the leaf with Henry the more I
felt like the cliche of the stoner who
just can't believe how beautiful
everything is the intricacy of that leaf
astonished me and I was reminded that
aesthetic beauty is as much about how
and whether you look as what you see I
was in short face to face with something
commensurate to my capacity for wonder
from the quark to the supernova the
wonders do not cease it's our
attentiveness that is in short supply
our ability and willingness to do the
work that all requires so in the end I
think Fitzgerald was wrong but I think
humans capacity for wonder is
nonetheless pretty great I give it a ten
out of ten highly recommended Hank I'll
see you on Friday